on va faire ça on va changer nos vies
tu prends les miennes tourner la tête on
échange de lui je prends la tienne mon
âme humaine ou naturelle
je prends la mienne celle ci [ __ ] de
tv2 ceinturait savoir monjuich et des
drogues
qu'est ce que tu as explique pourquoi
mes parents sont plus jeunes 4 sur 4 4e
jeu lange
mais moi une gifle quoi les moines
vivent comme ça on saura si c'est
vraiment nous voit écoute ou non 86
euros écoute on est aux 86 ruth fogel
est mort sur facebook la tête qu'il a
reçus sinon à plus ou moins 0 à s'cusez
moi désolé c'est moi oh pardon est et
ouest à table mais tu me donnes cet
album tu restes à table mais tu me
donnes cet abject
tu restes à table connais tu me rejoins
l'intérieur les parents de batteries
sont nés ici voilà
j'en ai envie je prends la tienne rideau
rideau